[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
appears morgan on censored tonight
britain burns and buckles on the hottest
day in this country's recorded history
if this is the new normal as scientists
say
what the hell are we going to do about
it
one of these three people we've
britain's next prime minister richie
sunak remains in the lead who will make
him sweat
and should preaching prince harry give
his big nose out of u.s politics he'll
debate that
would elvis presley have survived cancel
culture his wife priscilla joins me live
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm pissed morgan on sensor
welcome to blowtorch britain this is
what a record-breaking heat wave
actually looks like flames tearing
across parts of the capital at least
eight homes burned to the ground nine
major fires still raging as london fire
brigade declares a major incident 90
firefighters deployed to stop a wildfire
engulfing this major road in kent
all across the country people have
sweltered while services are buckled or
failed
no trains out of kings cross london's
biggest train station travel bedlam up
and down the country rail companies
urging people not to travel at all
official advice to stay at home it's not
safe to come out a dramatic spike in
calls to emergency services as fires got
homes and people fall seriously unwell
in the heat
flights delayed over melting tarmac even
airfields built for jet engines no
longer able to cope we used to say
britain passed in glorious summer
sunshine now it's britain burns parts of
lincolnshire hit 40.3 degrees today
104.5 degrees fahrenheit that's hotter
than the maldives ethiopia and jamaica
the simple fact is we're not prepared as
a country for this kind of torrid
temperature we know it's going to happen
more often we know that more people will
suffer and die as a result
so what do we do about it well i'm
joined now by jonathan smith assistant
commissioner with the london fire
brigade
well good evening uh to you um can you
just bring me up today mr smith on where
we are with what is clearly a big crisis
today
yeah so we declared a major incident
about two o'clock this afternoon due to
the sheer number of calls that we were
receiving from the public within london
um we've never seen this level of call
volume being received into our control
room we've had a number of significant
incidents spread right across the
capital right from uh major incidents
where we've deployed over a hundred
firefighters to bring them under control
through to much more lower level
incidents
most of which have been driven by the
heat wave that we've been going through
and the fact that the ground is
tinderbox dry so we've seen grassland
and woodland fires in particular but
then that has of course impinged on some
of our urban conurbations and we've seen
firefighters working in extremely
arduous conditions
right across right across the capital
we've seen the same with our home county
services as well who have also come
under significant pressure
we're urging really the public to think
very carefully and and moderate their
behavior over the course of the next 12
hours in particular that they're not
having barbecues in open parks and
spaces that they're being very careful
when they're extinguishing uh cigarettes
that they're not leaving rubbish around
particularly broken glass that can
reflect light and then cause a spark
i should say that we have been able yep
i should i should say that we have been
able to respond to every incident that
has come into our control room but we
have seen the brigade placed under
unprecedented pressure which was why we
kicked in our major incident protocols
which then stood up a lot of our
multi-agency arrangements with the
metropolitan police the london ambulance
services local government and the mayor
of london to make sure that we're ready
to deal with what the next 6 12 and 24
hours bring well you and your teams are
doing a fantastic job in very difficult
circumstances to those and there are
many of them on social media today
trying to play down this kind of heat
trying to play down the warnings that
are being given what is your message to
them
well our message is that this is a this
is what was once regarded as a once in a
generation type incident we are now
seeing time and time again and much more
regularly obviously the heat that we've
experienced today and some of those
temperatures around 40 or 41 degrees is
unprecedented but we are now starting to
really factor in the impact of climate
change in terms of all of our strategic
planning because we need to make sure
that firefighters are trained equipped
and prepared to deal with the challenges
that we know climate change is bringing
whether it's the significant heat
related issues we face today or whether
it's wide area flooding which is another
result of climate change this is a clear
and present threat and all of the
emergency services are now having to
make sure that we've got the right plans
in place so that we're ready to go when
these incidents happen again in the
future as we know sadly that they're
going to assistant commissioner thank
you very much steven you've got a busy
night and good luck to you and all your
teams
thank you very much
well let's pick up all this with
tonight's pierce back talk to me
contributor esther kraku i'm president
of the national union of students
larissa kennedy along with journalist
mark day from sydney she said today's
british where there's nothing compared
to some of the extremes they've been
having in australia and nico ramirez
part ranger in death valley in
california which holds a wreck over the
hottest place on earth recording 57
degrees celsius or 134 fahrenheit back
in july 1913 and environmentalist of
father boris johnson stanley johnson
welcome to all of you a big pack for a
big day and a big crisis let me start if
i can with mark day uh the former
minister of the australian um you're
over there in sydney i was in sydney
recently mark and it rained every single
day i was a all day every day it carried
on raining ever since i think it was
raining for much of the time before so
clearly a lot of climatic change going
on around the world in different ways
but what australia has had for a very
long time is sustained periods of this
kind of heat uh what is your message
really for britain as we now start to
experience what you guys have had for a
long time
yeah g'day peers
it's raining here at the moment uh my
message is that
it'll be hot next summer and it'll rain
next winter uh you know
climate change is very important no
doubt about that in fact i i was rather
proud of myself writing for the the sun
mccollum i didn't mention climate change
but that's what this is all about it's
it's it's getting hotter and it'll
continue to get hotter we've got to get
get used to it we've got to know how to
handle it and in australia we're well
trained at that well you are and i think
that's a key lesson for us here actually
we seem to be completely useless at
being able to deal with this because
frankly we're not used to it uh what is
the best advice for you that's right and
and
yeah and look i've been in london in 29
degrees and it
it it it was stonkering you know it was
worse than 29 degrees in london than it
is in 39 degrees in australia you know
you just you're not set up for it we are
because it we live with it and i mean
that's the message you've got to learn
to live with it because it ain't going
away mate no it certainly isn't um let's
go to nico ramirez park ranger death
valley national park it's been 120
degrees for the last several weeks but
that's almost a cool cool period for you
mr ramirez you are renowned around the
world for having the highest
temperatures uh when you see what's
happening throughout europe and now in
the uk
at the moment what do you think of it
what do you what do you make of the
climate change debate and what's your
view about this from death valley
yeah well uh
good evening to you pierce uh afternoon
here in death valley
that's a really good question so we live
with
hot temperatures all the time
and really what i can say is one of the
biggest things we push here is we
promote safety so
staying safe
we have a number of measures and
information that we give out to visitors
um that come to visit death valley
because one of the reasons they're here
is to sort of experience the heat of the
desert because the heat really is one of
the reasons that make death valley
special so listening to
your authorities and what they say about
heat safety is really important here at
death valley we do a lot of those same
things when we're hitting high
temperatures
we're doing things like uh staying
indoors
not spending certain amount of time we
have a heat safety plan which is really
important that we follow depending on
the heat temperatures are there's a
certain amount of work we can do outside
versus how much time we should spend
inside to stay safe and if it's too hot
we saw cease that uh
work all completely and we stay indoors
just like extreme temperatures where
it's cold we hibernate in the summer we
stay indoors in the ac
and we encourage people to stay in their
ac vehicles and
also just not
not push themselves or go any further
you you've
you've obviously seen the direct impact
of very extreme heat on a regular basis
how deadly can it be and there are some
people who just don't seem to take it
very seriously
yeah so um as um
uh the last speaker was saying uh we
live with it so um
one way that we do that and we manage
that is we acclimatize to it so we live
here it takes our bodies a little bit of
time to acclimatize to that but when
it's really hot uh pushing your bodies
outside of a limit on what you're not
used to is not something you should move
forward so we are promote safety and
caution first
up uh
foremost so that we're not putting
ourselves in situations so acclimatizing
avoiding the heat
staying indoors we have two we have
redundant cooling systems we have swamp
cooling system which uses evaporative
cooling and we have ac so that we have
backup just in case of the situation see
i think that's interesting because we
just don't we we don't have i mean i've
got a place in in california myself and
we just don't have that kind of
infrastructure you know it's not
embedded into british life because we're
just so unused to this kind of
temperature mr ramirez thank you very
much uh for joining me i really
appreciate it uh stanley johnson first
of all good evening to you
hey good evening good evening you've
been campaigning about climate change
for a long time i mean do you feel that
your
persistent warnings have been vindicated
by what we're seeing not just here but
also throughout europe i mean france in
particular is having a horrendous time
well i have been competing a long time i
was i remember getting to the very first
meeting of something called the
intergovernmental panel climate change
representing the eu in
november 1986 well that's 55 years um
before we had the paris convention
the paris convention
set a goal set a goal keep the
temperature
rise below
although two degrees center celsius
above pre-industrial levels keep it
below 1.5 if you can well
a lot of work went into the paris
convention a lot of when
went into the glasgow meeting we just
had
the idea there was to say are we on
track to keep these temperatures down
well the answer is who weren't on track
i mean people like alex sharma my own
son boris put a huge amount of evidence
to that
the answer is at paris and in glasgow
it turns out we're not on track now i
was very very impressed by what your
correspondents were just saying mr almir
there's no doubt about it that at this
present moment
the name of the game probably is
adaptation you actually have to work out
how to deal with the rising temperatures
which are there which are experienced by
people all over the world you know okay
we are complaining today about 40
degrees
celsius
you know 40 degrees celsius would be a
nice warm day um in parts of india you
know more used to 50 degrees well
adaptation crucially but picking up your
point is my message getting across not
my message because it's been messed up
scientists for 40 or 50 years
i think the message is getting across
what is not getting across is the
political action i got to say say to you
i have been disappointed looking just at
the domestic political scene over the
last few days and how little attention
the candidates have been bringing to
bear on this issue yeah i completely
agree i can pretty good they've been so
engrossed in their own power grabbing
they've forgotten that actually there's
a huge crisis unfolding right before our
eyes let's go to the esther here esther
what's your view about i mean the
climate change debate divides people
like everything these days
when you see what's going on here and
europe and so and you hear the arguments
it's inarguable isn't it that we are if
we're not very careful heading for a
apocalypse um i don't actually and this
is something that we argue within the
conservative party as well you know i
don't i i don't believe that any
rational person is a climate change
denier i don't think so i don't think
that's the case but you know like like
he was saying
we we've had these conferences and we've
had all these agreements like the paris
accord and you know glasgow but the
people that are polluting the most the
people that are really responsible for
this are not even in the room china said
they've committed to being net zero by
2060. they've laid out no plans for that
we don't even know how they plan on
getting there indonesia said oh yeah
we'll kind of do that narendra modi in
india 2050 how are we getting that we
don't know the uk produce
contributes about one percent of global
emissions and yet we're expected to
completely fundamentally you know change
our lives to to accommodate this plan
and the people that are really polluting
are not even playing their part and it
just makes you question you know that is
where the people i think that's a very i
think it's a very good point larissa you
represent students
young people are the future this is your
future that is being imperiled here by
political inaction
what's your view i'm in fact former
president so we'll say how you're on
your way out aren't you that's right
um but what do you understand what
students feel about absolutely and i
think there is a kind of readying number
of students who are looking at the
action that's being taken and saying
it's nowhere near fast enough you know i
was a cop 26 uh representing students
and there was a vast gap between what
was being said in the room and what was
being said on the streets by young
people who were coming from across the
world to demand radical change and
transformative action that reckons with
an issue that has been on the horizon
for a long time and yet we're still
seeing these massive companies that are
huge polluters who we know are
contributing the vast majority um to
break down are the tactics being used by
people protesting about this the right
ones in other words lying in front of
busy traffic stopping people getting to
school hospitals and so on you know
destroying or defacing famous artworks
uh you know the news uk building uh
vandalism just to get attention does
that actually help win over an argument
but i think what what's happening here
is that people are at loss as to what to
do because we've had the talks we've had
the summits we've had the conferences
we've had the annual meetings what else
do we do to the people to make us vote
this is the thing i understand these
arguments but my bigger thing is
we are not voting on these issues we
have people we have these economists in
switzerland and glasgow and all these
things making these radical decisions
for the british public and we're not
being allowed to vote you can convince
people you do not disrupt their lives
johnson said if if the three candidates
or as far as it was left to run the
country if none of them are talking
about this even as this massive heat
wave is erupting the highest temperature
we've ever had i'm not sure what would
but this is the driver particularly
the reason why they're not talking about
is because of where democratic pressure
is people are have feel alienated from
this conversation because they say
actually it doesn't really matter what
we say because there's going to be some
you know swedish um some swedish
teenager or some uh you know swiss
economist somewhere that says we need to
make decisions and forcing it down on us
so there's no point that is how you make
change you get people involved you don't
terrorize their lives by gluing
yourselves to roads and you actually
have a real conversation people depends
on how you define democracy because you
know when i've been on these marches
myself and the many peaceful protests
about climate action and often you hear
the chant this is what democracy looks
like it's people judging people
but i think i think i think marching
again
peaceful protesting is very effective i
think trashing historic art is
a self-defeating actually we're going to
take a short break let me come back and
talk about the tory pal leadership are
you excited by the prospecting any
candidates excited
you're going to need to roll the world
of tech because
and we have of course priscilla presley
who was married to elvis presley as this
movie goes around the world now
electrifying audiences we'll talk to
somebody who frankly knows elvis better
than any others priscilla there she is
looking fabulously glamorous over in
hollywood and we'll talk to her a little
later in michelle
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well the race to replace boris johnson's
prime minister is reaching the end game
just a moment i'll be talking his legacy
with his father's family johnson but
first an update on the leadership
contest kemi bhavnak has been knocked
out today that leaves rishi sunak penny
morton and liz truss to talk to the
political uh editor kate mccann is in
westminster visiting all the latest okay
uh we're down to the last three
my prediction right from the start of uh
rishi and trust with rishi is the winner
i think it's holding water do you see a
mordant surge to the top two
it's possible i think it's unlikely but
it's entirely possible and the reason
for that is because what's going on with
the voting at the minute is pretty much
entirely tactical just look at what
happened today for example rishi sunak
he only added three votes to his number
after 14 yesterday does that sound like
it makes any sense and the fact that
penny morden yesterday went backwards
and today piled on 10 votes despite the
fact that many more of tom tugan hats
were expected to go her way and for that
matter liz truss who's the candidate
probably least aligned with mr tugan hat
seemed to grab the most of his votes
something fishy is going on in
westminster and mps are talking about it
tonight in fact there are reports that
rishi sunak is on the terrace of the
house of commons now that's unusual and
what it tells you peers is that even the
front runner isn't necessarily a hundred
percent confident although i think he's
fairly certain to be in the final two
because the votes could well change
tomorrow if tom tugan has votes move
from liz trust to another candidate and
of course depending on what happens to
ken kemmie badenock's votes from today
they could well favor liz trust the
question is when it all shakes down
there are a group of conservative mps
who want to see penny mordant and rishi
sunak in the final two do they have
enough votes between them to make that
happen or will it be as you say the more
predictable result of liz trust and
rishi sunak going down to the wire well
it's very fishy but my money's on rishi
uh mainly because he's so dizzy
we're gonna leave you there
sorry kate can i apologize to you and
the nation for that appalling series of
puns appreciate you joining me as always
let's pick up with boris johnson's
father stanley johnson stanley who's
your money on to be the new leader
well i'm not that i'm not betting i'm
not betting but i want to pick up on the
use of that word fishy
well fishy now i think we saw a recent
week say truly fishy a squalid
a squalid political assassination is all
i can is all i can say appears at this
point really of your son
a squad political assassination which
bears no reference to my mind to the
achievements which he put out his
administration put out and i i do get
that i was i wasn't brexit
richard was one kobe was another
the environment we were talking about
the environment the beginning of this
program well he really pushed on the
environment and
the violence and then you've got ukraine
so honestly i am bewildered and
you know well in the end in the end
stanley he lost the trust of 60 of his
own senior ministers
because they were sick and tired of the
lying over party gate and then pincher
gay and all the other things i mean it
wasn't because they simply woke up and
thought we're going to assassinate him
they have they've been driven to the end
of their tether would be their argument
that's what you say that's what you say
so i i have a much blacker view of this
whole thing i have a much black and i
don't i don't see anything in this
except political opportunism by the
opponents some of the opponents were in
the house somewhere on the other side of
the chamber that's the way it went
policy is a tough game i hope that
life pans out again in a different way
do you think that rishi sunak is the
biggest culprit in this political
assassination i i don't want to get into
that either well i'm what i'm saying is
that any objective view and i spend a
lot of time traveling abroad they can't
believe what happened in this country
they simply cannot believe that a
politician the prime minister was
elected with with a majority of uh i
think 80 or over 80
and a massive uh popularity larger than
their we've had before cannot believe
that a handful of people can turn him
out that's that's my position now and
but it's much more important this moment
to concentrate on quote unquote the
legacy and i think you know there we
there we see there we see real real
opportunity to build on that and i think
the environment is one of those things
by the way i think building bridges with
europe is another one it's another one
well hang on come on
stanley i mean say building bridges a
year it's your son that took us out of
europe and it's like a massive two
fingers up to europe so i'm not sure how
that's going to be his legacy
i'm saying that once we're out of europe
what was the big challenge the big
challenge was create a new architecture
in europe and we didn't do that and i
think we would have been doing that i
for example wants to rejoin the european
environment agency which allows for
countries like switzerland and turkey
and always
that's why not sweden
by the way i'd like to just get back
into that can i ask you
sally can i ask you um
does boris does boris believe that he
was the victim of a political
assassination
if he doesn't he doesn't read enough
noble perspectives as far as i'm
concerned
you must have told him
and uh
this to my mind was a put up job from
beginning to end
that that's how i see it and i think
that we will learn our lessons on this
one and we'll learn our lessons that you
can't proceed in a democratic way by
this sort of mechanism
right but that is of course how he
himself took power isn't it
well he took power but he had the grace
within weeks of taking part to go to the
country and get a
mandate from the country as he did in
december 2019.
okay so stanley look i understand your
loyalty is as his dad and it's very
admirable but do not understand a lot of
this boris brought on himself
i mean the repeated the repeated lying
the party gate scandal was enough to
have toasted most prime ministers he got
fined by the police for breaking his own
rules the way he he behaved over pincher
gate was ridiculous and in the end i
think a lot of his his top people just
threw in the towel because they could
feel confidence in the government had
just been shattered do you not accept
that any of that could be correct yes i
i
reject every single element
of your dossier i just i just don't see
it but he can't
reject the fact he got fined by the
police for breaking his own law
hold
doubt that the cabinet on
have gone over the limit um the speed
limit who had signs i don't think that's
been fined you know and politicians do
get fined i mean frankly i understand it
was a fictionality notice and as i have
the story it was his birthday and he
picked up the glass
in the thing i i am not ready to accept
your language
okay all right okay look stanley well i
have to agree to disagree i i fully
understand
as a father myself why you feel the way
you do and if you're loyal and you feel
he's been betrayed and assassinated
others will disagree but i appreciate
your candor now thank you for joining me
it was a pleasure pierce good to see you
quickly
boris johnson's dad there saying
he was a victim of a squally political
assassination pretty strong a victim a
victim boris johnson has led this
country into disrepute time and time
again um you know many students young
people are exhausted by having this
person uh represent the country in such
a way that uh you know is divorcing us
from our partners in europe that has uh
you know not been serious when it comes
to climate action you know the world is
burning the country is literally melting
and the conversations that we're having
to have because of the way that he has
led the conservative party in the
country are just embarrassing there are
so many things that should be on the
agenda right now about repairing post
covid the gaps in our education system
the gaps um in our uh social care
systems and yet we are here in such a
what seems to be such an undemocratic
process where many people across the
country are so divorced from it it's
just disempowering and very alienating
really esther your reaction to well
boris's defense and also what there is i
mean i completely i i understand and i
completely agree with you and i
understand obviously boris's father
because it's not easy to see that um but
obviously the country has spoken i just
want to say on the point of kind of this
undemocratic sort of leadership contest
it would be the same if some of the
labor yeah yeah party
exactly if you vote for a party they're
free to choose you know at the end of
the day the candidates for the
leadership contest are not stupid right
they're going where they think the votes
are they're speaking about the things
they think their base wants to hear
about so i i completely get that who do
you think do you think is going to win
um i i i call me crazy i still think
that is going to come down to sunak and
mordent and if that is that's tsunak's
worst
who wins
because the thing is those those mps are
thinking who's going to go
i'll stay by my original tip rishi we'll
see what happens thank you both very
much for joining us i know you're
fleeing the country to get away from me
so i look forward to seeing you
you are not involved you said you were
coming back last time and here you are
you couldn't you couldn't resist me
lovely to see you elizabeth and safe
travels unsensitive next prince harry
has been banging on to the americans
about how awful they are again i'll get
a reaction from an american
about this
tv personality comedian and red-blooded
american captive will be given her view
on harry's comments
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
welcome back to pierce morgan uncensored
now to the group from twosome friends of
the show harry and megan harry was that
it again yesterday entering the
political fray in america with another
rambling speech
i wonder how it went down though with
americans here is a clip
we're living through a pandemic that
continues to ravage communities in every
corner of the globe
climate change wreaking havoc on our
planet
with the most vulnerable suffering most
of all
the few
weaponizing lies and disinformation at
the expense of the many
and from the horrific war in ukraine
to the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the united states we are
witnessing a global assault on democracy
and freedom
well joining me now is fox news
contributor all around american gal kat
timf welcome to your cat um your
response to this haughty prince
lecturing you about how to lead your
life
yeah i really can't stand the climate
lecture from somebody who took a private
jet most assuredly to go give that
speech i i can't believe i mean if we
compared my climate footprint to his
there'd be no comparison whatsoever and
look if i had private jet money i'd take
a private jet he obviously was born into
those kinds of connections and if you're
born a prince you generally have
advantages that almost no one else will
have to make your life whatever it is
that you want and to do whatever it is
you want with maybe one exception and
that is to be a professional victim
which unfortunately seems to be the
career path that he's most attracted to
is he is whining at every chance he gets
about almost everything non-stop without
offering any sort of solution or even
acknowledgement for the way some of his
own behavior might contribute to the
problems he's complaining about right he
also likened his struggle for freedom to
nelson mandela's who just remind
everybody spent 27 years in a 6x6 prison
cell do you see any comparison between
the two struggles
i certainly don't see to see a
comparison i think it it's such a
glaring glaring difference that we
really learn a lot more about who he is
again i think all americans because
there's a handful of people in the world
that are just get that kind of privilege
just by based on you know where they're
born into and how they're born he's one
of those very lucky few so all of the
rest of us don't want to hear him
whining about his struggles no doubt he
has had struggles in his life but i know
that that kind of privilege and power
makes any kind of struggle much much
easier for you yeah of course it does
now america unfortunately is two for two
in sending your women over here to and
beagle their way into our royal family
the first was wallace simpson who led to
an abdication of one of our kings the
second is meghan markle who's wrestled
harry away from the clutches of his
family and taken him to make hundreds of
millions of dollars from the royal
titles they were afforded by an
institution they professed to despise
what's your viewer meghan markle
apparently she's thinking of running for
president
you know what i bet she does
i mean the all of the they love the
attention so much and it's just so
remarkable how much attention they're
able to get and how much money they're
able to get the both of them despite i'm
not really sure what it is that they're
good at i mean even this most recent
speech from harry he was going on and on
about the loss of freedom in america
even though he himself called the first
amendment bonkers he was on a podcast
what he said was uh you know i've got
much so much i want to say about the
first amendment as i sort of understand
it but it is bonkers i mean
that
that is not exactly the most astute
analysis that i've ever heard and this
is the kind of thing where you're
getting hundreds of millions of dollars
for analysis like that and then not even
acknowledging your hypocrisy when
apparently you don't stand for freedoms
in this country
it blows my mind it's a great gig if you
can get it honestly
i have one
we've been so lucky we'd all love a gig
i'd love to go on harry's struggle it
must be so uh struggling uh cat great to
talk to you thank you very much you too
thank you
well he was the king of rock and roll a
global icon would you survive today's
cancel culture i wonder who better to
talk to you about elvis presley and his
first wife priscilla who met elvis when
she was just 14 and was married to him
for six years i'll talk to her about the
king and this amazing new movie which
tracks their life together and sense of
next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back i'm delighted to say as i'm
joined by somebody who knew the king of
rock and roll elvis presley like a few
other people in the world priscilla
presley married elvis in 1967 they were
married for six years she remained a
constant in his life
despite all the controversies she
remained loyal to him to the end and
priscilla joins me now live from los
angeles welcome to you priscilla
thank you thank you pierce
i was just imagining that the movie is
just exhilarating and fantastic i want
to play clip first and then come to you
i'm going before the show
[Music]
i just gotta be making the most of this
thing i can
this can all be over the flesh
[Music]
[Applause]
presenter i found it unbelievably
exciting to watch this and i never knew
elvis presley you were married to elvis
presley what was it like for you to
watch this movie not least because
there's a character of course playing
you
oh well um i
to be honest with you i was very nervous
about it because it's baslerman
and as we all know baz you know has his
own unique style which is good
but i just didn't know how he was going
to portray elvis and i was concerned
very concerned
um baz wanted myself and jerry schilling
who used to work for elvis to go to new
york at the gala mets gala
and also to go to cannes film festival
and i hadn't seen the film yet so i
bowed out gracefully and said there's no
way i can see it because obviously i
don't know anything about what you're
doing so he arranged a
screening for
jerry and i at warner brothers
and we didn't speak for i guess
three-fourths of the movie
and i bent over
and said to jerry well it looks like
we're going to cannes
it was good
it was good i have to say i i was i was
completely engrossed in it as as well as
jerry
um
boston austin austin butler did an
amazing job it was i mean he had elvis
down to a t
literally
he um
studied him for two years
you see that's fascinating because i i
just assumed he had him down to a t
uh you would know better than the most
because elvis is such a unique performer
people have tried to emulate him over
the years i think with varying degrees
of success do you think austin butler
has got him better than anyone that's
ever tried
hands down
better than anyone anyone
um my daughter was quite emotional when
she saw it as i
and went my god i i i mean he has
he just it was like watching elvis his
movements his smirk his walk his
attitude his temper i mean it was it was
like reincarnation i mean it was it was
beautifully done beautifully and olivia
deyoung plays you were you happy with
that portrayal
yes i was i mean i never we never talked
baz did all the talking of course
um but
i i thought she did a a very nice job
she was sensitive to him which i was
always to him and his needs and
what he was you know trying to do with
his life and
what he wanted out of his life
so i thought she did a very nice job
elvis was without a doubt one of the
most brilliant talents that the world of
entertainment has ever seen that's
unarguable he was also quite a
controversial figure in many ways do you
think you would have survived
this weird cancel culture that we now
have to endure
that's a good question i think of that
often
you know what would elvis think what
he wouldn't believe what is going on
right now to this country or
to all over what's happening to
this planet
he was very concerned about our
presidents who was ruling the country
he
and people would never believe that but
he was an avid reader as well
and not just um
you know
religious books but also
he was reading what was going on in the
u.s
what would he have made you think of of
what is currently going on in the u.s
i'm sorry what would he have made you
think of what is currently going on in
america
oh no he wouldn't believe it i mean he
he truly
you know i don't believe it i don't
think any of us believe what's going on
right now we've never been through
anything like this and it's pretty much
global but us as a country
it's baffling it's truly baffling i'm
for the first time worried about my
future for not only my children my
grandchildren as well
very unpredictable and elvis would um
probably go to the president
like he did with nixon yeah put his foot
down and say what's going on
what is it that you find particularly
saddening or worrying
oh my gosh the state that we're in
i mean
my gosh i don't know what happened to
freedom
i don't know if there is freedom here
anymore you know no one says what side
they're on republican or
whatever you want to be
um
being very careful what you say how you
say it
uh
i think we're in a very dangerous time
we're at a strange stage priscilla where
even high profile women are scared to
say what they think a woman is
that's true
that's true how sad is that
and i mean
it's uh
to watch this going on being very young
in the limelight and
knowing a lot of people who are in the
limelight
their fears
on what's going on not not that they're
just in the limelight but i think it's
it's spread quite a bit uh
in this country about where we're headed
uh and i often think like you asked
you know what elvis would think you know
what would he do
he he just he wouldn't he wouldn't
believe it he was a die-hard american
he was america yeah
he he loved this country he loved it
but it seems to me it seems to me
priscilla there is a there's a kind of
movement not just in america but i'll
talk about america about this there's a
movement to try and trash everything
that's come before and that's why i was
curious whether you felt elvis whether
there would be a campaign to try and
cancel him for you know inappropriate
statements inappropriate behavior
whatever it may be inappropriate lyrics
we've seen it time and again now with so
many people that's why i was curious
what you felt because it seemed to me
he would fly in the face of so much of
what this weird culture represents
well per the movie if you saw and you
did see the movie you know a long time
it was um stated that elvis you know
uh was um a racist
he was not a racist he's never been a
racist elvis had friends black friends
friends from all over
um he loved their music he loved their
style
uh he loved being around you know black
musicians i mean that's domino when he
was in vegas he was in the lounge
playing and he would always we would
always go and hang out with him
sammy davis jr the same thing but always
come into the dressing room and he
loved loved being around blacks and
being around anyone actually he was just
not prejudiced in any way
so and not racist in any way so i don't
know you know this is a very frightening
time
um for someone i don't it's almost like
you know we're looking for something
from everyone that we can somehow
dispose them in some way yeah and
that's why it's so frightening right now
was elvis the great love of your life
yes he was
he obviously he obviously sang about
love so many times
when you're on your own perhaps is there
a one song that elvis sang
which resonates most with you
oh my gosh you know there's so many
songs
um
gosh
that's hard to pick that's a hard
question that's the hardest one you've
asked me
um
[Laughter]
gosh what's the one when you hear it
well i think it's been in las vegas
watching him do the shows
and um
i think you know the songs that he's
saying that people were all drawn to
uh and and i think that
you know all of us are attached to a
song there's so many with him um i can't
even i can't even tell you it's now or
never probably yes now or never because
i heard him sing that in
germany actually
and
and that was given to him
through the record label
of the company and uh to watch him
sing the song and try to reach the notes
and perfection is what he was looking
for to perfect those notes because he
his tone his his
his uh pitch was not as high uh
in in that particular song so he would
always
try to reach it and mess up and then hit
his leg and
try it again and again and again so
watching him kind of rehearse and trying
to get it right is is was an experience
you can
do you wish priscilla in a way that you
had
never got divorced from elvis and do you
think that his life would have been
different if you'd stay together
um
gosh
um
to be honest i think we were better
not married
um we had a great relationship
he would come over to my home at all
hours of the night
talk it could be two o'clock three
o'clock
um i would have my daughter awake my
daughter up be with us at some of that
my mother the same thing all the lisa
had to go to school
he would come alone sometimes and
sometimes bring charlie hodge one of his
guys that worked for him or someone else
and we'd just sit and talk and he'd
bring him books and he'd read books to
me
and he left me with quite a few books as
well
but
we see everything just seemed to be more
relaxed more at home when the tension
wasn't there now remember i'm with elvis
presley
and um
watching the girls
running up to him wanting kisses from
him
running to the stage uh
coming backstage
it's a you know it's
listen being who he was
and having all the women you know
jump him
excuse me
um i'm kidding i'm only kidding
i think you're already half kid against
periods
[Laughter]
literally just about um anyway
no it was it was um it was
an eye-opener for me and on i'm
being married to probably one of the
most famous musicians or singers in the
world
i love everybody there isn't anyone that
doesn't love elvis right and i love how
affectionately you talk about it you
know not many divorced spouses would
talk with the kind of love
and admiration that you have for him so
many years of course after he sadly died
he was a great human being he really was
and he tried so hard
you know at what he did to be perfect
and in many many ways you know he wanted
a movie career a good movie career that
was one of the problems as we know you
saw the film that elvis had him tight i
mean that colonel had him tied up with a
five-year contract with hal wallace of
all people
you know hal wallace um
did more cutesy movies girls on the
beach as we know um never really gave
him the part that he longed for yeah the
james dean part
uh that's really what he longed for and
you know what priscilla he had he had
one of the greatest careers that the
world has ever seen in entertainment and
he was a true icon and the movie is
utterly fantastic i'm so glad you loved
it as much as i did we said i've got to
leave it there but i could talk to you
all night thank you so much for your
time i really appreciate it
thank you thank you so much
well that's all for us tonight just
remember today a scientific survey came
out saying marmite is good for your
anxiety i'm good for anxiety good night
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm holly hudson a major
incident has been declared in london as
hundreds of firefighters continue to
tackle a number of blazes this evening
at least 10 broke out in and around the
capital amid a record-breaking heat wave
several people were taken to hospital
and had to be evacuated from their homes
as fires destroyed buildings
temperatures have hit 40.3 degrees today
making it the hottest day ever
unions are threatening more strike
action if pay rises aren't increased the
government's announced the majority of
nurses teachers and police officers will
get a hike of four to five percent and
kemi badanok won't be replacing boris
johnson as the next prime minister she's
been eliminated from the tory leadership
race leaving liz trust penny mordent and
rushi sunak battling to make it to the
final two tomorrow that's all for now
we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you